Our first example today
is a story of IBM Watson.
IBM research, a distinguished
industrial laboratory,
strives to push the
limits of science.
In the mid-1990s it created
Deep Blue, a computer that
beat Garry Kasparov, the world
champion in Chess at the time,
showing to the world that
machines can beat humans
in tasks that
people thought were
restricted to
human intelligence.
In the 1990s-- in
the late 1990s--
it created Blue Gene, a computer
to map the human genome.
In 2005 IBM decided to
create a computer that
would compete at Jeopardy,
a popular game show.
From the T.J. Watson
Research Center
in Yorktown Heights,
New York, this
is Jeopardy-- The IBM Challenge.
Please welcome back
our contestants.
He has never been defeated.
And his winnings of
more than $3.2 million
make him Jeopardy's all
time biggest money winner.
From Los Angeles, California,
here's Brad Rutter.
An IBM computer system able to
rapidly understand and analyze
natural language,
including puns, riddles,
and complex questions across
a broad range of knowledge,
please welcome Watson.
In 2004 he captivated America by
winning 74 consecutive matches
and $2.5 million on Jeopardy.
From Seattle, Washington,
here's Ken Jennings.
And now here is the host
of Jeopardy, Alex Trebek.
Thank you, Johnny.
Before we get into
the game, there
are just a couple
of things I need
to tell you about this match.
Now as I said earlier,
Watson will receive the clues
electronically as a text file
at the same moment the clues are
revealed to Ken and Brad.
And at the same
time I read them.
This competition
will be a two game
total point exhibition match.
However, these two games will be
played out over the next three
days so we can tell
the full story.
Throughout the games you'll
get a glimpse of the thinking
process, if you will, that
is behind Watson's responses.
Now this will be done through
an answer panel display
at the bottom of the screen.
Let's play Jeopardy.
Here we go.
Our first round of play
contains these categories--
Literary Character APB, All
Points Bulletin; Beatles
People; Olympic Oddities;
Name the Decade;
Final Frontiers; and
Alternate Meanings.
A little while ago
we had a drawing
to determine which player
would select first.
Brad, you won that.
So if you're ready
make your first choice.
Let's take alternate
meanings for $200, Alex.
Four letter word for a
vantage point or a belief.
Brad?
What is a view?
Yes.
Alternate meanings, $400.
4-letter word for
the iron fitting
on the hoof of a horse or a
card-dealing box in a Casino.
Watson?
What is shoe?
You are right.
You get to pick.
Literary Character APB for $800.
Answer the Daily Double.
Now Watson, although
you have but $400,
you know of course
that you can risk up
to the maximum value
of a clue on the board.
And that is $1,000.
$1,000, please.
All right.
Here is the Daily
Double clue for you.
Wanted for killing
Sir Danvers Carew.
Appearance pale and dwarfish.
Seems to have a
split personality.
Who is Hyde?
Hyde, yes.
Dr. Jekyll and Mr. Hyde,
either one acceptable.
You're now in the
lead with $1400.
Go again.
Beatles People for $200.
And any time you feel the
pain, hey, this guy, refrain.
Don't carry the world
upon your shoulders.
Watson?
Who is Jude?
Yes.
Olympic Oddities for $200.
Milorad Cavic almost upset this
man's perfect 2008 Olympics,
losing to him by one
hundredth of a second.
Watson?
Who is Michael Phelps?
Yes.
Go.
Name the Decade for $200.
Disneyland opens and the
peace symbol is created.
Ken.
What are the '50s?
Yes.
Final Frontiers
for $1,000, Alex.
Tickets aren't needed
for this event,
a black hole's boundary from
which matter cannot escape.
Watson?
What is event horizon?
Yes.
Why is Jeopardy hard?
Jeopardy asks the contestants
to answer cryptic questions
in a huge variety of categories.
It is generally seen as a
test of human intelligence,
reasoning and cleverness.
No links to the outside
world are permitted.
And new questions and categories
are created for every show.
Watson is a supercomputer
with 3,000 processors
and a database of 200
million pages of information.
It has a massive number of data
sources like encyclopedias,
texts, manuals,
magazines, Wikipedia, etc.
IBM researchers who
developed Watson
used over 100 different
analytical techniques
for analyzing natural language,
finding candidate answers
and selecting the final answer.
We'll discuss this more
later in the class.
In February, 2011, a two
game exhibition match
aired on television six years
after the initial conception
of the idea to build Watson.
Watson competed against the best
two human players of all time
and challenged the
meaning of intelligence.
Now Watson is being used for
many applications including
selecting the best course
of treatment for cancer.
What is the edge in Watson?
Watson combined many
algorithms to increase
accuracy and confidence.
We'll cover many of
them in this class.
IBM approached the
problem in a different way
than how a humans does it.
Watson deals with
massive amounts of data,
often in unstructured
form, which is important
as 90% of the data in the
world is unstructured.